Well, good morning again church. If you're new to our church,
we're grateful that you are here. Thank you. Please come say hello
to somebody we did have a great week of VBS as you've seen already
that it's an honor to get together as a church
like that and serve together with with such a great staff team
and hundreds of volunteers on the team. It really doesn't
happen without that. And so just want to say thank you
for praying and giving and serving so that it
would happen because hundreds of kids heard the gospel over and
over this week. They knew they were loved and they had
a great time of course with it.
So, thank you.
But today we're continuing through our Series in Jesus's
parables in Luke and we're looking at these stories
with a purpose and why did Jesus tell them and what did they mean and
this morning? We're going to see a parable that will again as most all
of them have illustrate how the values of this
world are often backwards to the
values of God's kingdom and how he
says he wants his people to live.
And as I was thinking about this one this week, my sports brain immediately
went to scoreboards.
You know, what a scoreboard is right, you know the primary purpose
of a scoreboard is to tell the score
of the game.
Well more than that. Really when you look at a scoreboard you're
looking for who's winning the game, right? You're
trying to figure out how much time is left. But really the point is who is
ahead.
And that works in Sports. No problem. That is absolutely fine.
but in life
as we'll see in the parable that will study today.
We can easily trust in the wrong scoreboard.
We can trust the wrong scoreboard in life,
especially.
Dealing with money.
Now here's what might be easy for you to do with this
as we go through today.
As you listen to this you might think and be
tempted to write it off as not for
you.
That it doesn't apply to you because you're not like Scrooge
McDuck remember him like swimming through his
money like that. You're not that and so you're like that. This isn't
about me.
But I believe that God.
Wants to show each of us.
How Deeply
the deception
of the American dream has bled into every
one of our hearts.
That we have a false view of success.
and fulfillment
that if I can just get my retirement fully funded then
then I'll be secure.
Or I want a little bit bigger house always or
or I I want to a little safer
neighborhood or better schools or whatever it is.
And we try to climb this ladder all in
a comparison game with everybody else around us.
That's the point.
See often we trust in the wrong scoreboard.
To see whether we are winning in life.
Luke 12 will press on that deeply today.
And so if you're not already there turn with me to The Gospel According to Luke.
3/4 to the way through the Bible or so third
book of the New Testament Matthew Mark then Luke.
We find it look for the big number 12. That's the chapter
number.
Luke 12 is where we'll be.
The question we need to ask first is what do we learn from this
Parable as we look at this Parable? What do we even learn as
with the other Parables? What's Jesus trying to teach us about his
kingdom about how we are to live in light of his kingdom.
It's what The Parables were for he's separating from the
kingdom Seekers from those who aren't seeking. So what he's showing
us here.
Well here in Luke 12 this point actually starts in
verse 13.
It's before we get to the actual Parable is
not even there yet, but it sets the scene for
why he told the parable here in a second.
So let's look at verses 13 through 15.
Someone in the crowd said to Jesus teacher tell my
brother to divide the inheritance with me.
But he said to him Jesus said back to a man who made
me a judge or arbitrator over you.
And Jesus continued to say to him take care and
be on your guard against all covetousness.
For one's life does not consist in the
abundance of his possessions.
Now remember at the time the inheritance of family would
pass on to the next generation was not divided equally.
That's the word divide there. It was an equal Division and this
man was was wanting the equal division, but actually the firstborn would get
more than the rest of the sons, right.
And so right away this man's question shows his selfishness shows
his jealousy as the younger brother. He's like, hey,
let him divide it with me.
That's why Jesus warned them the whole crowd about
living as if material things are the
Savior that that's where life is found.
And so what's interesting about this parable about to study
is that he actually gave the meaning of the parable before he said
the parable?
That's the meaning right there.
He used the parable in a second as an illustration of
his point, which the point here clearly was to
beware covetousness.
The question prompted his teaching was
beware.
Covetousness beware Being Greedy beware this
desire for more this Envy of others.
So his point beware covetousness and
we need to feel the force.
Of what Jesus said here in verse 15. There's a lot going on here.
See the words Jesus used here in verse 15.
I mean pay careful attention to study make
sure you don't miss anything. And then also he says
actively guard yourself against some
enemy coming.
Imagine a city with walls, he would say
this like post-centuries up on the walls to make
sure that you see an attacker coming and you can make the
first shots.
That's the intensity level.
Jesus brings against covetousness against every
greedy desire for more
in your heart
and why was he so intense because he says
your life.
your your life
Not just your breath and blood flow your life.
Does not consist in the abundance of your possessions.
Many life is not truly measured by how
much you own.
We put another way stop trusting the
wrong scoreboard.
That's not success. That's not value. That's
not worth.
So beware covetousness, but then thankfully Jesus defines
what that looks like.
Well, at least one way greed shows up and
that's the parable of the rich fool that we'll see here in a second.
Look at verses 16 through 21 Jesus continues in the
same conversation.
To the crowd verse 16 he told them a parable.
Saying the land of a rich man produced
plentifully.
And he thought to himself what shall I do for I have nowhere
to store my crops.
And he said well, I'll do this. I'll tear down
my Barns and build larger ones.
And there I'll store all my grain and my
goods.
And I will say to my soul soul. You
have ample Goods laid up for many years. Relax eat
drink be merry
but God said to him.
fool
this night your soul is required of you.
And the things you've prepared who's will they be?
So is the one who lays up treasure for himself and is
not rich toward God.
So Jesus already said Beware covetousness that's his point.
Here, the illustration of the parable leads us
to believe and see that we need to also flee foolishness.
in that same process
beware covetousness and flee foolishness
as you do that
I mean as you read back through the parable think about how
many times this Rich fool said I
It's actually six times the word I shows
up and then another five times my shows up,
right?
And that's on purpose. Jesus is just illustrating. This man's selfishness.
This man thought that having a solid 401K would
free him up to relax to spend his days
live in the high life going on vacations going
golfing spending time with parties and friends like
he thought this was gonna be the dream.
Here's the thing though.
If every one of us in this room was brutally honest.
all of that
Sounds pretty good, doesn't it?
Like we want that kind of life. We we're up.
It's appealing to us. In fact, like that's what
people work for.
To retire early or to be able to retire at
some point just say here's what I'm gonna live for.
It's like it's like heavy from Fiddler on the Roof. If
you've ever seen that musical when he was told that money is
the world's curse.
He responded. Well, may the Lord smite me
with it. And may I never recover?
There is this there's this low-grade greed that
all of us have like man, I would be great. I'd love to have
that.
but again
the man and the parable had made it he had it all he
was set.
Yet the first word out of God's mouth in
verse 20 is what?
fool
God called this man a fool.
Now wait a second.
I thought God was loved God is love right. That sounds
pretty harsh. How is he? So unkind to this
man now God loves everyone. Yes.
And he loves everyone enough to tell them the truth about the
status of their life and their heart and
their future.
And for this wealthy man the evidence of his
heart and in his life pointed to nothing but
arrogance and greediness.
I mean just think about what happened here first. He failed to
acknowledge that the land had produced plentifully.
Like in the end he had nothing to do with the results.
Right. Yeah, we we plant and we water yes, but the
growth is up to God not to us.
You can do everything right and and it still doesn't produce right?
So he failed to acknowledge God and that but even further once he received
this massive Harvest his first thought
was to selfish materialism.
He did not acknowledge God in any way.
That's what Psalm 14 verse 1 actually says the
fool says in his heart.
There is no God.
Whether you actually believe there is no God.
Or whether you just live like it.
It's foolish.
Now again, let's go back to what I said at the start you might be
looking at this Parable and think it's not a problem for me. I'm
just trying to make ends meet like I barely have enough at
the end of the month every month like how this is not a problem
for me, but remember this
You don't have to have a lot to be greedy.
to be materialistic
It's all about your heart.
That you selfishly want more.
To have more Comforts and more conveniences or
nicer and newer things.
It's the same heart problem this man has.
And plus as soon as we start to live as
if we don't need God.
That what we have in this world will sustain
us not him. Then we start
to get off track.
So whether you can actually ever obtain it
or not. Don't let the American
dream Define the way you live your life.
It's the wrong scoreboard.
Because Jesus says here's the way to avoid that.
To truly take to heart the question. Jesus asked in
verse 20
Which by the way the only time God shows up as an actor
in a parable is here in verse 20.
Where God shows up to this man and asks a
question remember what it says God said to
him fool this night. Your soul is required of you the things
you have prepared. Whose will they be?
Meaning they're not going to be yours anymore.
And so what Jesus did with this Parable is he
flipped the scoreboard on this Rich fool?
By saying the most important thing is not how much you have.
The most important thing is where is your soul going?
What's going to happen with your soul?
This man's Day of Reckoning came.
Just like it's coming for you and for me.
And listen, you can't stand before God and impress him
with your 401k or your house or
your bank account or whatever else. You can't stand there and
press God by the way, all that's going to somebody else anyway.
You don't get to take it with you. The only
thing that matters on that day is his view of your soul.
Whether it whether your soul whether you turned
from sin turn from materialism and
turn to Jesus life death and Resurrection in
your place. Did you do that? Do you value him? It's
what Jesus said in verse 21 is he continued that
this is most important. He said so is the one who lays up
treasure for himself and is not rich toward God.
Like the comparison game there.
What that means is you have a choice where you're
going to place your satisfaction.
Where you are going to place your hearts treasure?
What he says here is that temporary riches will not
last are not satisfying. So instead of
pursuing those things cherishing those things cherish
godliness.
At this point with verse 21 cherish godliness.
Be rich toward God.
This is trusting the right scoreboard.
This is where you know, your soul is
most important but but think about that phrase what is being rich
toward God even mean.
I mean, he's going to give me a wealth. What's he talking about
here? How can we be rich toward God.
Well that word Rich means to be plentifully supplied with
something.
Money here, of course, but but it can mean other things plentifly supplied
with something. So what what's he talking about
being rich toward god, well in the context of spiritual riches the
thing you're plentively supplied with is Grace, right?
It's Grace.
That you're a big sinner.
covered with bigger Grace
you are rich.
wealthy
that even though you didn't deserve it God chose you and saved you
and covered all of your sin with his son's
blood. That is true wealth, right?
And that's what makes us truly Rich According To Jesus because what
that leads to is then our new aim
in life is to serve him as king spend
his resources entrusted to us for his glory for
his kingdom. That makes us then wealthy Rich
toward God.
I love how First Timothy 6.
Sums all of this up. So well talking about this tension
that we're walking in. It says godliness with contentment
is great gain.
For we brought nothing into the world. We cannot take anything out of
the world. But if we have food and clothing with these will
be content.
But those who desire to be rich fall into
temptation into a snare into many
senseless and harmful desires that plunge people into ruin
and destruction.
For the Love of Money is a root of all kinds of
evils.
And it's through this craving that some have wandered away from
the faith and pierced themselves with many pains.
See the rich fool in the parable.
He missed life.
By presuming that possessions are life.
When actually godliness with contentment is
where true life is actually found.
But here's the problem with all this.
See, you know as well as I do.
That the cultural current in which we
live.
Flows in the exact opposite direction of this
mentality.
everything around us
And even much of what's inside of us?
It screams for us to be selfish and
materialistic and greedy.
right it
the system is designed.
To make us discontent in our lives.
Every single commercial you have on television.
It's designed.
To make you want more and new and better.
to compare
and so when we look at what Jesus said in Luke 12
What first Timothy six it is? Is that impossible?
Is what Jesus said impulse, how can we possibly do
all of what he just said to do?
Like how can we guard ourselves against greed?
When we fill this constant pressure to keep up with the
Joneses.
Again, I've said this before I'm sorry. If your last name is Jones, that's just unfortunate with
that, right?
How can we flee foolishness
when when all of the world is about
bigger and better and self?
How can we cherish godliness in this
kind of world that we live in? It's nearly impossible, right?
Well, thankfully Jesus followed up the parable that he
just taught.
With with further teaching on how we can
ever do this how we can pursue godliness how we
can trust the correct scoreboard in our
lives like we can see him show us how to do it.
In the first way is by remembering
that God will provide.
We are able to resist greed
to flee foolishness and trust this
scoreboard that Jesus puts in
front of us because we know he's going to provide for
our needs.
We keep reading in Luke 12 starting in verse 22.
See what Jesus says to his disciples now. He
talked to the crowd told the parable, but he remembers dividing and
his disciples then need to hear this.
He said to the disciples. Therefore I tell you do not be anxious
about your life.
What you will eat nor about your body what you'll put on.
For life is more than food and the body more
than clothing sounds familiar, right?
Consider the Ravens they neither sow nor reap they have
neither Storehouse nor barn and yet God feeds them.
Of how much more value are you than the birds?
And which of you by being anxious can add a single hour to
his span of life if then you are not able to do a smaller
thing as that. Why are you anxious about the rest?
Consider the lilies how they grow they neither toil nor spin
mean they don't work at all yet. I tell you even Solomon in
all his glory was not arrayed like one of these
but if God's so close the grass, which is
alive in the field today, and tomorrow is thrown into the oven. How
much more will he clothe you?
Oh you have little faith.
And do not seek what you are to eat what you are to
drink nor be worried.
For all the nations of the world seek after these things and your
father knows that you need them.
Instead seek his kingdom and these
things will be added to you.
See what Jesus just said.
Is that we are able to focus on the true life
that he offers us by seeking his kingdom
first.
By seeking him leading us to then stop
worrying. Like we're putting our focus on him. It leads
us to stop worrying so much about what he's going to give us
whether we'll have enough or not.
If we trust him that he is the king he is
our good father. He's going to provide.
Like with the birds here, right? Jesus mentioned these birds.
You don't see them renting out storage units,
right?
Like I kind of chuckle every time I drive down the road because it
seems like everywhere. There's a new storage unit being built.
If that's not an indication that this is a problem for
us in America. I don't know what is
just garages full of stuff and stuff and
stuff, right?
The birds don't do that.
They just trust their father. They worship they live. They
seek the kingdom in a sense. That's what they were wired
to do.
and God provides
when we trust God's provision, then we're less
susceptible.
to the Trap of materialism
to trusting stuff instead of God
But there's a second way Jesus says he says not only
is God going to provide for you. He also says shift your
scoreboard because God's also going to bless you.
God is going to bless you to bless others.
Look at verses 32 through 34. He continues all
about this theme of don't be anxious. Don't worry fear
not little flock.
For it is your father's good pleasure to give you
the kingdom.
Sell your possessions give to the needy.
Provide yourself with money bags that do not grow old
with a treasure in the heavens that does
not fail where no Thief approaches and no
moth destroys.
For where your treasure is?
There will your heart be also.
Talk about the kingdom talking about true wealth and here Jesus ties it with
generosity.
He says here's what it looks like to trust the kingdom is
to give generously because God's going to provide joy in
all that you do in that because think about that word treasure,
right?
That word treasure means when something is considered
valuable.
I've used this one before but like Gollum with the
ring, right?
My press right. So he's he's treasuring
that ring. What because
he sees in his valuable. He sees it as Something's Gonna
Give him Joy gonna be his hope in all of
life. That's what he's finding the pirates with the treasure chest.
That's what they're looking for to find Joy the
rich fool in the parable.
Was finding his treasure in more stuff more money
more ease.
At that money and resources would give him the relaxation and partying
that he's so craved and that that was what he was trusting in
and Jesus called that foolish.
But I want to flip the script.
Here for a second.
What if that same man?
Treasured joy in the Lord instead.
He was trusting and treasuring this stuff. What if instead
he was actually treasuring joy and look
what if he cherished godliness as Jesus said he should
and when he received all of the extra he gave the
extra away.
That's what Jesus just said to do, right what he had enough for
him and his family. He saved some for next
year, but then he just blessed his village.
think of the joy
for them
and for him
What if the man would have said John Piper put it this way? What if
the man would have said?
God this is all yours.
You have made my Fields Prosper show me
how to express with my riches
that you are my treasure and the riches are
not.
I already have enough. I don't need a bigger safety net. I
don't need better food better drink better parties.
I do want to make Mary. Yes, but not in
self-indulgent parties with Rich retirees.
I want to make Mary with the people who have been helped by my generosity.
I want the fullest blessing of giving
because Jesus you taught me. It is
more blessed to give.
Than to receive.
Like what if that was this man's perspective?
What if he gets this huge evidence of
God's blessing and that's his perspective
because remember this this man had no idea that
that was his last night.
Didn't know it was coming.
He thought he was Secure.
He thought his wealth would prevent death, but it didn't.
Plus think about the man never even got to benefit from it.
everybody else did
He just missed out on the party.
right
Everybody else got all of the extra.
he could have
had a part and enjoyed it with them.
And so listen, one of the common questions that we talked a
lot about money the last month or two.
If God gives you the ability to make a lot
of money.
Great.
Notice the man was not called a fool for being a
productive farmer.
He was not called a fool for being wealthy.
the question
is what will you do with it?
the question is
Does it lead your heart to be thorny soil?
Where that materialistic life chokes
out the work of God in your life.
Does it lead you to be thorny soil or does it lead you
to be more generous?
I started in first Timothy 6 earlier. Here's how
it continues.
It says As for the rich in this present age
charge them not to be haughty or arrogant nor
to set their hopes on the uncertainty of
riches as we see in the world around us right now.
But on God set your Hope on God who richly
provides us with everything to enjoy.
They are to do good to be rich in Good
Works to be generous and ready to share.
The storing up treasure for themselves as a good foundation for
the future.
So they may take hold of that which is truly life.
You're blessed to be a blessing.
It's where life is found.
but in all this
there's an implication of a warning here.
That if we are seeking life in our stuff.
Or in the pleasures of the world rather than
in God himself, then we need to beware.
Just in the parable itself. There is a warning like
that Soul was required of him that very night.
There's a day coming when Jesus will
return and call the question on us.
Jesus will return.
In fact, that's how he continues as he's teaching his disciples how to
live this truth out. He says in verse 35 stay dressed
for action.
Keep your lamps burning and be like men who are waiting for their Master to
come home from the wedding Feast so they may open the
door to him at once when he comes and knocks blessed are
those servants whom the master finds awake when
he comes?
Truly I say to you. He'll dress himself for service and have them recline at
table. He'll come and serve them. This is talking about eternity.
Jesus showing that to his disciples. We're seeing it forever if
he comes though, listen 38 if he comes in the
second watch or in the third and finds them awake blessed are those servants?
But then he kind of shifts the parable but know this that if the master
the house had known it what hour the thief was coming. He would not have left this house
to be broken into.
Kind of a second the idea that if you know when the thief
is coming you're not gonna leave the door wide open.
But verse 40 this is the point. You also must be ready.
For the son of man is coming at an hour. You do not expect.
the rich fool
doesn't matter how much you have on that day.
If all you've been living for is your house.
Or your car or your resume?
Or your collection of seashells.
Or Vacations or whatever it is. If that's your
focus what you're going to hear on that day is full.
Today your soul is required of you.
And the urgency implied here is that no
one knows when that day will be.
You don't know when that Reckoning moment is coming when the
judge will come back. And so you better be ready all the time.
It might be tonight.
That's why you cannot say I'll take
care of it. Later.
that's why you cannot say once I get my 401k funded
then I'll give
or I'll follow Jesus wholeheartedly once I get out of college. I got
I got to enjoy this, right?
Do not delay.
James 4 says it clearly come now you who say
today or tomorrow will go into such and such a town and spend a
year there and trade and make a profit yet. You do not know what tomorrow
will bring. What is your life? You are
a Mist that appears for a little while and then vanishes.
Instead you ought to say if the Lord Wills will live and do
this or that meaning it's up to God as it is you boast
in your arrogance. All such boasting
is evil.
So whoever knows the right thing to do and fails to do it for him.
It is sin.
We've seen it clearly today.
What will it profit a man if he gains the whole world yet
forfeits his soul.
the current of the world is
pulling us toward trusting the wrong scoreboard.
And I was thinking about this last night that the relevant question
came up in light of Father's Day today.
And so dads, let me ask you mom's you're
included in this too. But the dads let me think with you for a second.
What's the goal you have for your kids?
Is it that they would be prosperous and moral?
Just decent human beings who are able to make a lot
of money successful.
again that ends
in despair
It's antithetical to God's kingdom values.
Because our true goal for our kids should be to help
them adore Jesus and to help them join him
in bringing in God's Kingdom.
That is absolutely number one over
everything else.
Because remember God would much rather us be rich toward him
than Rich here.
And there's a huge difference between those two things. That's the
right scoreboard that we focus on godliness. We we focus
on a relationship with him. We focus on building up
other believers and giving generously and prioritizing the
kingdom of God. That's what life is found
in.
That's what the martyred missionary Jim Elliot once said.
He said he is no fool who gives up
what he cannot keep to gain what
he cannot lose.
Don't trust the wrong scoreboard for you
for your kids.
Give your life.
To the secure one.
named Jesus
but here's how I want to close.
See the goal of all of this today is not to create.
some feeling of Works based salvation
and we just walk away beat up by these impossibilities.
Now we should be absolutely critical of American materialism.
Yes.
Because it's so often the stumbling block
in the way of our pursuit of Jesus.
We should call it out rightly.
But hear me the hope of the Gospel in light of
this Parable the hope of the Gospel is this.
On the day that Jesus does return.
On that day you die or Jesus
returns. You will not be presenting to him the last
thing that you did with your life.
And you better make sure it's right. You better make sure that you get
it all together in that. No, you will be presenting to him the
last thing that Jesus did with his life for
you.
Right because remember Jesus lived the perfect life you
could never live. I mean he overcame greed and covetousness perfectly.
He lived a perfectly wise life
was never foolish and he cherished his father above
all else in his life. Then he carried
our imperfections to the Cross. That's
what you will hold up and say this is my only
hope
If you're holding anything else up.
How well you did how generous you were you're holding anything
else? It's not going to make it Jesus in your place
is the only thing and that's what the Lord will judge you on.
That's what then if we really get that into our souls
what motivates us then to do that.
We've just said the whole time.
That's what motivates us to say. I want to know him more. I
want to make him known more. I'm gonna release everything
counted all as loss for the sake
of knowing him.
Is only when you know, you're going to stand before Jesus
secure.
forever
that gives you the courage to do all the other stuff we've talked about
today.
This Jesus is better.
Than anything else Church?
so let's believe that more today and tomorrow
and the next day then we ever have
he is better.